frecuentemente se dice que la monarquía
británica es la más famosa del mundo
porque tanto protagonismo a este reinado
en la actualidad una historia que ha
sido recreado en series en películas en
libros
etcétera
buenos dias angela qué gusto saludarte
bueno lo que pasa es que es la monarquía
más antigua al final y que ha dado los
números récord que yo creo que nadie
podría igualar a lo mejor la única
monarquía que se puede igualar en cuanto
importancia es la monarquía español y
sobre todo también yo creo angela por
los momentos históricos que ha vivido la
monarquía los windsor y al final la vida
de isabel segunda ella cuando era
princesa todavía dividió la parte final
y la y la segunda guerra mundial y ayudó
junto a todos los británicos a
reconstruir ese país y de eso han pasado
70 años imagínate y la lógica y lo
histórica que es la vida liza del
segundo que a lo largo de su reinado han
pasado 14 primeros ministros este
winston churchill quien fue quien
prácticamente le enseñó a hacer reina a
darle ciertos consejos al igual que su
padre porque sexto y que ahorita hemos
visto pasar 14 primeros ministros dos
mujeres margaret thatcher pérez a male
hasta llegar a evolución sobre tela
esto fue con toda probabilidad del
último jubileo de la reina isabel como
se ha transformado la idea de la
monarquía desde su llegada al trono hace
70 años
a lo largo de estos 70 años la revisar
el segundo ha tenido que hacer ajustes
en esta modelo ya que ha dado de alguna
manera ella se ha tenido que adecuar a
los tiempos que ha vivido y eso lo hemos
visto tan sólo a mirar que la propia
noche la reina nos robó el corazón con
este vídeo con con el osito paddington
en donde ella básicamente muestra yo mis
96 años de edad también puedo ser
divertida y ningún gran sentido del
humor la reina y que no son cercanos a
ella han podido constatar este sentido
del humor ahora ella mostró un poco de
ese ese carácter esa risa el poder
también disfrutar esta fiesta por sus 70
años entró no al decir pues aquí estoy y
también ha dado en este jubileo es
importante angela el hecho de que ya
empezó a dejar quién va a estar después
de ella cuando llegue ese momento y
quien ha tenido ya un gran protagonismo
en este jubileo precisamente ha sido el
príncipe heredero el príncipe carlos
eran es bueno y tampoco es pobre que de
probable que volvamos a ver un reinado
así de largo y esa era la parte bella
pero también están los es y las
denuncias contra la monarquía que les
espera
bueno pues sí yo creo que al final el
príncipe carlos lo tiene muy claro
y esto se ha visto ya después de que
javi negra los que se shocks es
renunciaron a la familia real civil ahí
fue donde la reina pues hacer ajustes y
le empezó a pasar los ciertos
caminos que tienen para la monarquía que
la familia real será más fuerte y eso lo
vemos tan solo en el balcón cuando puede
que al final del desfile del tracking de
color donde vimos a la reina rodeada de
su heredero el príncipe carlos y la
duquesa camila de cornualles y por el
otro lado estaba el príncipe william
y con sus hijos esta va a ser la nueva
monarquía y que lógicamente se va a
modernizar en cuanto la reina
el rey también en ese para ese entonces
el príncipe carlos pues va a tener
también que poner su estilo en esta
monarquía